congratulations you are pregnant with
your second child second child it's
number two
really happening do you have three yeah
three i know i kind of aspire to three
but then i think that sounds like a lot
take your time yeah we'll see
uh okay so how do they handle this on
cougar town for your character well what
was great about we made the move to tbs
this year when we're neighbors we're on
the same network now and um
our we ended up shooting
up until i was like 12 weeks pregnant so
we were able to hide the stomach but i
will say that my boobs grew three sizes
in this season so that's something fun
that you can look out for that is that's
that's the best promotional uh
was on your show last week or the week
before and she was saying she had
declared it since we were going to be on
cable it was going to be racier yes and
she had declared it the season of her
cleavage yes she was showing a lot of
cleveland yeah oh my husband noticed it
the other night he's like what's going
on with courtney's shirts they're very
low cut and um and then it ended up
being my season of my boobs just
expanding they're expanding uh
this is of course a natural phenomenon
pregnant women they're getting ready
they're getting ready to feed the child
no matter how i talk about this it
sounds creepy coming from me
the breasts expand
i should have the bangs down for this
the breasts expand
as the baby grows
this is really terrible that's awful i'm
sorry
our people obviously are your your cat
crew cast they're all noticing this
phenomenon yeah so everyone was really
excited about it but i hadn't told a lot
of people that i was pregnant because
you know you like to keep it a secret
when you're a lady for a little bit to
be safe and um but courtney cox and
krista miller the two ladies on the show
knew and every day i would walk to set
and they would just be ogling my chest
and chris
as soon as i would walk on set she would
say can i touch him today
okay sure and they were actually really
warm to the touch now the three uh the
three or four they were they were like
why are they giving up i don't know they
weren't radiating heat conan and the
three the three or four boys that we
would be working with josh hopkins and
ian gomez and uh brian van holt who
didn't know what was going on would just
be staring at this at their crazy female
co-stars like touching each other's
boots well just mine really just my
boobs but it was fun so
i just want to intern there uh
you know this is a crazy time to be uh
celebrities a lot of famous pregnancies
right now i know uh and and of course
kardashian and kanye
you know almost as excited about that
baby as i am my own really yeah
for real i was mentioning to someone the
other day who my ob gyn here in los
angeles is who delivered my first child
and will deliver this one and
my friend said oh yeah he was on the
kardashians
he delivered the sisters babies you're
obg my ob gyn so
could be that we have the same ob gyn
so there's a possibility there's a
possibility
that we could be in the hospital and he
could be running from room to room yeah
except there'll be a lot of cameras in
the other room
what are you talking about i have a ton
of cameras
no i don't know
that shouldn't be something i love how
that's something we're ashamed about now
there were no cameras to record nobody
cares during that sacred moment
they give off heat eh
is there nothing they can't do
like an episode of the prospector in the
coupe
[Applause]
so this week the prospector and the cool
guy tackled the case of the laser boobs
the good show stupid show
yeah
i want to congratulate you are the new
sag awards media ambassador what does
that mean well basically the sag awards
asked me if i would go to the sag awards
and stalk celebrities on the red carpet
and like make them take twit pics with
me right um and then i people can follow
my twitter account and i'll be giving
them like the inside scoop on what's
going on any fun though who's eating
what i'm gonna try to get a picture of
daniel j lewis like midnight
of his of his lunch that yes anything to
demystify
that very talented i just want to bring
him down i want him to be it's time
someone brought that guy down right yes
it's gonna be all of america is ready
for it i'm terrified